nourris on va démarrer avec enora et
nora qui va aider voilà qui va aider la
liste bretonne qui va aider du 17
exactement automne donc sur le trampo
des gogos allez-y n'aura alors elle sait
bien on attend d'abord il a fallu
fischer entama chéri d'amour prévu au
métro à ce que je peux revoir si vous
avez prévu
laurie laurie c'est la noc
quand vous êtes en cours en quatrième
elle valait ce basket le mercredi après
midi
merci glissé mardi un arbre à côté de
nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si lors il est là bas écouter j'aimerais
bien être à la racine de l'arbre si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire il a ses
vapeurs
alors j'avais coloris alors ça c'est que
je ne sais pas si vous avez vu ça chez
vous il a juste faire là j'aime beaucoup
le ring c'est un gain de taille déjà
dans un télégramme tu fais un mail je
plusse va pas les mettre à l'arrêt
moteur à parce que sinon il lui
arriverait donc au nombril mais n'aura
souri quand la police froid sur l'europe
alors est ce que l'on rit est ce que
l'on arrive à faire mieux lors ici on
chaque ballon crevé donc c'est sûr euros
pour l'unicef
il ya de tout bois n'ya de toi alesi a
même attaqué dans un palais c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
attendez on arrête toi va tout péter
laurie l'horrible vous aimez le surf
aussi j'ai vu ça j'ai fait une itv de
kelly slater alors tous ceux qui nous
regardent comme inspecteur c'est c'est
vraiment c'est dans le surf c'est que je
vais vous dire si certains des plus
grands champions de tous les temps du
surf est aussi même tout sport croome
et puis très beau ma mère est tombée
amoureuse de lui l avez jamais vus à
l'antenne il a fallu que l'on présente
les championnats du monde de surf en
france pour pour quel âge à draguer
michaud par ouais non non non il a une
petite copine qui est très mignonne et
son chihuahua et on touche pas qu il est
7 heures non mais ça c'est assez drôle
parce que finalement c'est un mec assez
vrai pari il en impose quoi tu le vois
il parle de son chien et tu vois il son
chihuahua ça fait bien vous allez là je
me 7 sur coup faisait pas fait 30
millions d'amis qualité
[Applaudissements]
wow factor attention attention
allez ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
sentimentalement nom me peu ce qu'est le
calme le calme alors je vais vous dire
c'est le calme peut-être avant la
tempête
je vous le dis on aura mais on se
connaît on se connaît valait pas tout
seul tant les chéris vous vous
connaissez vous a déjà raillé
non non on a dîné ensemble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
telus a on était à roland-garros était
la soirée blanche cette année d'ailleurs
et en fait on se rencontrait parce qu'il
y avait toute l'équipe d'eurosport qui
étaient installés là-bas j'étais l'ami
le riz ils étaient là comme ça vous ayez
tous à la même table
il est venu à côté d'où il est resté et
au loin que ses copains mais non il est
s'était arrangé pour keynes et
étiquettes à côté de leur it in même
pour me dire et alors ça je pourrais
être votre style de michelle mais
attention aux riches moi je préfère je
préfère qu'elle est c'est d'ailleurs
face à l'américain kelly slater kelly
slater et doit justement il va se mettre
en chemin
- ouais mais là je vais vous dire là à
mon avis le temps qu'il arrive au niveau
de kelly slater
je pense qu'on sera en 2047 donc éclater
cinq ballons ou huit ballons cinq
ballons et bien écoutez je rajoute les
deux ballons et on donne 1000 euros pour
l'unicef
merci beaucoup non non non attendez
romero métaireau mais t'es foutu de ma
gueule
les gars comment vous allez me di mino
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les gars on vient de tirer une carte
chance la marque erreur de la banque en
votre faveur
on donne 10 millions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]